hi everyone this is unit big Hummer
bringing you the highlights from the
world bullets championship monkeys
Colson had a great first day scoring
nine and a half points out of 12 it was
a bit shabby at times he managed to
rescue a lot of very suspicious
positions but I want to highlight this
game he played against Iranian with the
black pieces and this was just
spectacular chess
Iranian played pawn takes d4 and instead
of taking back this pawn magnus moves
his knight up to b3 now iranian is known
asked the chess player who offers the
most exchange sacrifices so here with
the knight threatening that the rook in
the corner he just ignored that and he
just kept on capturing Magnus's pawns
and leaving the the rook arm pre however
magnus showed that a runyan is not the
only one who can sacrifice an exchange a
knight for a rug so he went rogue takes
f3 which is it's it's crazy but it's so
good at the same time at least for
entertainment the Queen cannot take back
because then the bishop is gonna be in
trouble so a runner took back with a
pawn and now once again Magnus has the
option of capturing the rug but instead
he chooses to capture the bishop takes
back takes back Knight takes e5 if we do
the material count White is actually has
a pawn and a rook for a bishop but it's
not that easy because you have really
damaged your pawn structure and after
Knight takes D 3 black was able to win
back the exchange and and the the pawn
structure in front of White's King
being damaged the the game continued
rook t1 c4 and now Magnus is looking at
some threats with the bishop pointing
towards the White Queen and King and
what I find really fascinating about
high-level chess is that you have these
crazy sequence of moves and then it you
know the dust settles and turns out it's
all pretty equal in the end anyhow
because aronia now made a good practical
decision to give back a rope for the
night and after Queen takes Queen takes
Queen takes the position was still very
much unclear Magnus with the black
pieces managed to win this game and this
sequence of moves to me was the
highlights of day 1 of the rapid of the
bullets championship